so
there's a lot of work that sasha
shilligan and albert hoffman
who invented lsd and first synthesized
psilocybin on what they call structure
activity relationships
what is the structural of the molecule
and then how do you predict
what that new molecule that never
existed before is going to do
once you actually take it and
you can get close but you never really
know
until you actually take the drug and the
way that
um sasha ran his experiments
is that he would take the drugs himself
first
in low doses and he would sort of you
know step up the doses to have more
experiences if he thought it was
valuable he'd share it with his wife
anne
but then what they would do is if they
both thought it was valuable they had a
group of 12 people that they were with
for many many years
and they would distribute these new drug
to these 12 people
and they would get the different
perspectives and he felt that 12 was
like a minimum number you know because
we're so unique how each of us see
things but then you kind of get a little
bit of a consensus on how a lot of
people are going to see it and then if
that
12 people were positive about it then
they would turn it over to leo zeff
we called the secret chief the leader of
the underground psychedelic therapy
movement and then he would start
exploring it in therapy
so there's still a lot of mysteries as
far as structure activity relationships
and
it's not going to be the case that
people go into the lab and
they tinker with molecules and they know
exactly what they're going to get
and a lot of it has to do with the not
so much
chemistry as morphology you could say
the shape of the molecule and how does
that
interact with receptor sites and so
we're getting better at
modeling all of that
you